hi i'm katie storino founder of mega
babe and i'm here at the digital hub
ready to answer your fashion questions
because this is fashion fix
[Music]
yes the first place to start when you're
looking to revamp your style or just get
a fresh take on your look is to look
around for inspiration what are
celebrities wearing that you love who on
the internet are you really feeling
influenced by don't worry about those
little voices in your head that say you
can't wear this you can't pull that off
let's just start with finding
inspiration and then we can start to
shop and pull those pieces into your
wardrobe and start to try them out
[Music]
you don't have to avoid chubb rub at all
with clothing because you just have to
use mega baby thigh rescue it's why i
started my line because i wanted to wear
skirts and dresses without having to
wear another layer underneath
[Music]
the best tips for styling for winter
without feeling like you're hiding your
body are to lean into
prints
layering
i actually think winter is like an
easier time to feel more stylish because
in the summer i'm just too hot so i love
playing with clothes in the winter
[Music]
before i embrace my body i actually
never wore jeans i didn't even own jeans
i just thought i was not made for jeans
avoid jeans and now i'm kind of a denim
queen
i started make my size because i was so
frustrated with the shopping experience
of not having clothes fit me and trying
on the largest size that a brand made
only to find that it was like the zipper
was still open this far in the back and
instead of crying and you know like
returning all the clothes and just
putting all black on i actually took to
the internet and said hey designers i
want to wear your clothes i'm the
average sized woman in this country
there are so many other women who want
to wear your clothing as well please
make my size
it's not me
it's it's the clothes essentially like i
know that my body is good and fine
that's the first thing to remember the
second thing to remember is that sizing
is all over the place with brands you
could buy the same size from two
different brands and they're they're
they fit totally differently because
sizing is very inconsistent and we just
we don't know what the process is for
making clothing and we can't really let
that process we have nothing to do with
affect how we feel about our body
my favorite super size the look i would
have to say is a meghan markle denim on
denim because it got me
to wear
a canadian tuxedo for the first time
because i was like ah i don't really
think that's my vibe it's not my style
not my energy but uh i wear it all the
time and then with the camel coat on top
[Music]
every spring and summer when it was side
chaff season i was so over using these
really gross products that that had
chemicals in them they're made for men
they were embarrassing to pull out of my
handbag and i was like eff it
i need to make this i know nothing about
making beauty products but like
girl i'm going to figure it out and i
did
[Music]
mega wave actually is self-funded and we
took a total risk on products that quite
honestly people in my family told me no
one needed and the gamble paid off
because we we sold out of our first run
of thigh rescue and bus dust in the
first month that we launched and now
we're sold at every alta every target
across the country we make clean
products for women that are not tested
on animals and we tackle the taboo
issues that people really don't address
in the beauty industry
[Music]
i have seen a noticeable shift in the
industry how serious and how deep it
runs and the longevity of it i i think
still remain to be seen thanks for all
your questions and thanks for having me
drew
[Music]